the church of el paso on the foothills
of kumbreva in spain's la palma island
with each explosion comes a prayer
for those who have lost their homes
another for the people of el paso
and for the island of la palma
experiencing disaster
[Music]
i am here to trying to find some peace
and to find the strength to accept this
new reality of ours
it started last sunday as a small
eruption look at it now the crater is
widening showing cracks with the
overflowing lava turning this once green
landscape into ash
six thousand people have been displaced
homes businesses and places of worship
the lava is swallowing entire villages
in its path
spain's gorgeous seville are extending
the cordon around the volcanic eruption
and while the village here of el paso
has not been evacuated this could change
at any moment's notice because this is
what's worrying authorities here
it's as if the village is slowly being
buried under a thick blanket of ash
the volcanic cloud has created a
microclimate with ash falling like rain
levels of sulfur dioxide in the air is
suffocating in some areas forcing people
to leave their homes unaware if they
will ever be able to come back
the trauma of loss is immense it's not
just one person losing everything it can
be an entire generation from
grandparents to the grandchildren they
are in shock going through various
phases of grief from denial to sadness
and anger to a changing environment
with the environment they once knew
suddenly lost the volcanic eruption has
left the people of la palmascard
and in grief
nature has taken its course from the
ashes of their home
already
a new landscape is forming
nicholas hawk al jazeera el paso la
palma spain